تنهمر دموع هذه السيده حزنا على ابنها
الذي لم يرجع الى المنزل اما هذه الاوقات
فتبدو فيها اسعد وهي تستعيد صوره عبد
الواحد مجيد المولود في بريطانيا عام 7 9
وهو الى جانب دراجته
الاولى واذا سرع الوقت قليلا الى فبراير
نجده هنا مع مقاتلين جهاديين الله اكبر
لحظات فق قب مهمه انتحاريه في سوريا لقد
اتصل بشقيقه حافظ في انجلترا قبل
اسبوع ولد مجيد خارج لندن من والدين من
اصل باكستاني وعش طفوله بريطانيه طبيعيه
هنا صور للعائله اطفال بزي المدرسه سياره
جديده واقارب قاتلوا في الجيش البريطاني
وهنا في مسقط راس كراولي ربطت وسائل
الاعلام مجيد بامام مسلم وب متطرف مسلم
ادين في مؤامره ارهابيه سابقه لكن لم توجه
له اي تهم ولم يدن
سابقا الصيف الماضي يعمل سائقا لشاحنه
صيانه ثم سافر الى سوريا ضمن هذه القافله
التي نظمتها منظمه خيريه بريطانيه مسلمه
اما زوجته واطفاله الثلاثه فقد بقوا في
منزلهم بينما ذهب صديقه زهيد محمود
معه تظهر هذه الصور مجيد وهو يعمل متطوعا
في مخيمات اللاجئين فما سبب تحول هذا
الشاب الذي يرتدي قبعه ميني ماوس هنا الى
يقول محمود انهم التقوا ب متمردين سوريين
من ضمنهم مسلحون من داعش ومتطرف تابعون
لتنظيم القاعده في المخيمات
لكن محمود يقول انه لم يكن يعلم بتجنيد
مجيد ومهمته الانتحاريه خطط لها مسلحون
شيشاني انشقوا مؤخرا عن داعش وجبهه
النصره هذا هو فيديو هجوم مجيد على سجن
بحلب الذي كان مسرحا لعملي تعذيب ينحى
فيها بالائمه على نظام الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد شملت مئات السجناء حسب ما ورد
[تصفيق]
لكن الحكومه البريطانيه لا تشارك هذا
الراي الصوره على درجه واضحه من التعقيد
ولا تمنح اجابات عن الكيفيه التي ينتهي
بها صبي بريطاني الى انتحاري في سوريا
واكثر من تبحث عن اجوبه هي
الام